this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by
Aura like the Hubble before it the James
web telescope has given us images of
deep space that challenge our view of
the universe and our place in it every
day we discover new galaxies stars and
planets some of these discoveries can
even exceed our own imaginations but we
spend so much time exploring the heavens
that it's easy to forget about the
Mysteries right here at home 70% of the
earth's surface is water are the C Clark
famously said how inappropriate to call
this planet Earth when it clearly is
ocean as of 2023 less than 25% of the
seaf floor has been mapped less than 10%
of the ocean has been explored in the
tiny amount of exploration we found
things that defy logic and challenge
history sunken cities ancient monuments
and objects that look like they're from
another world the more we explore the
more we learn we know nothing about What
Lies Beneath the waves more people have
walked on the moon than have been to the
deepest parts of the ocean so with all
due respect to space the real final
frontier is the
[Music]
sea can I help you yes this is K out of
vand camp with the uh the Goldfish Hall
of Fame I need some information on a
hang on let me check here uh Mr Heckle
fish morotti well I'm Sorry Miss Vamp oh
carada please well I'm sorry Carla but
we don't give out employees personal
information
employee I was under the impression that
Mr morotti was more like a peer or
family member well whatever your
impression we don't give out personal
information
crap I mean thank you and have a
wonderful
[Music]
day oh thank goodness I've reached you
human I'm in person I never met you
before I'm a Dr Alfred farington the
third I need to reach a a Heckle fish
mariati immediately I'm afraid there's
been a terrible accident really what
happened I uh I a milk truck K into his
dear camel G it means lost control I
know what it means Mr farthington Dr
farington then you know how important it
is for me to reach Mr got immediately
please give me his name address and
email well Gertie's fine I'm looking at
the cameras right now and she's with her
mother trying on my wife's shoes I told
her to covered cameras before why are
you calling me pretending to be someone
else you knew it was me yes I knew it
was you Dr carlot V whatever crap I knew
I should have used my Stasi wig are you
sure that wig wasn't Hutch it's sty what
do you want yeah fine this morning I was
going Googling myself and my personal
information is all over the Internet
we've clearly got a security leak you're
the only one who knows all this stuff so
you must have spilled the beans whoa
whoa whoa what makes you think I'm the
security leak well I already water
boarded the Beavers but they didn't seem
to mind it beavers live in water you
know I didn't call you for your beaver
expertise I got to find our security
leak there is a Traer in our midst hang
on didn't you order high heels for
Gertie online well yeah but the guy in
the phone told me they don't share
personal information look just sign up
for Aura aa oh is that today's spons
well yes it is Ora can identify data
Brokers selling your info to spammers
and robocallers and Aura can submit opt
out requests on your behalf and Aura
does a lot more than protect you from
data Brokers you can set up antivirus
VPN parental controls password
management and identity theft Insurance
all for from one easy app at one
affordable price H well that sounds good
but I'm a little busy helping Gertie and
a mother try on all these shoes oh B
I've never seen so many camel toes in
one place well you can either let people
continue to exploit and profit off your
private information or you can go to
aura.com yfiles to start your 2E free
trial or just click the link in the
description
aa.com yfiles got
it I'll do it in just a minute today
Gertie wants to role play a fairy tale
oh boy yeah we're doing Cinder camel and
the handsome fish I already got the evil
stepmother take it easy M it's just a
game hey does your wife have anything in
a size 52 she doesn't crap fine change
your plans honey uh today we'll play
Goldie camel and the three beavers yeah
I'd rather you didn't look that's enough
chitchat I got to go look up the recipe
for
porridge h
in June 2011 divers Peter Lindberg and
Dennis orberg were treasure hunting in
the Gulf of bnia in the Baltic Sea Peter
had made a name for himself a few years
earlier when he discovered a merchant
ship that was sunk by German OTS in
World War I the wreck was loaded with
hundreds of bottles of rare conac and
Brandy the bottles were sold at auction
for $20,000 each in today's money that
was enough of a egg for Peter to launch
ocean x a deep sea exploration company
professional treasure Hunters Peter and
Dennis knew the ocean floor beneath the
busy shipping lanes of the Baltic were
loaded with prizes to this day two or
three dozen ships go missing every year
many of those disappear in the Baltic
they were on a routine survey Mission
when their sonar got a
[Music]
hit everyone on the ship gathered around
the machine to see what they discovered
the sonar slowly started Ed to paint a
picture they couldn't tell what it was a
merchant ship a submarine was it
anything of value when the image finally
finished processing it revealed a
circular object that didn't look natural
it looked man-made well maybe not
manmade it looks like a UFO it looks
like the uh aluminum Falcon Millennium
Falcon what' I
say it was 200 ft wide and was lying at
the end of a channel whatever the object
was it looked like it had hit the water
and slid hundreds of feet across the sea
floor the object appeared to have a hull
with Chambers and sections with straight
lines and right
angles Peter and Dennis gave the crew
orders don't say anything about the
object until they figure out what it is
snitches get stitches well they were
just trying to protect the site they
didn't snitches get stitches fine rules
of the street rules of the sea anyway
they studi the image for weeks and were
stumped finally they decided to go
public the image went viral and landed
in every newspaper and every broadcast
in the
world buckle up Star Wars nerds you're
going to like this one can only be
described as the wreckage of a crashed
spaceship the genie was out of the
bottle there was no going back they came
across something
unusual now everyone on Earth knew
something mysterious was happening at
the bottom of the Baltic The Hope was
all that media coverage would help
finance a return expedition to the site
if they could get back there they'd dive
to the object they'd map the entire area
in 3D so the team started pitching
investors and sponsors sponsors wanted
to know is this an alien craft we don't
know is it a natural formation we don't
know maybe it's proof of the lost city
of Atlantis well it's not Atlantis no
why not well because in 1968 Atlantis
was already found
in June 1938 Edgar Casey lay back on his
couch and closed his eyes after a few
minutes of deep breathing he started
mumbling then forming full sentences he
was in a trance Edgar Casey was called
The Sleeping Prophet because this was
his process he went into a deep state of
relaxation like sleep and had visions of
the past present and future Casey gave
thousands of readings where he predicted
future events and many of these came
true he predicted the stock market crash
of 1929 he predicted the discovery of
the Dead Sea Scrolls he saw the rise and
fall of Adolf Hitler he predicted Laser
Technology before anyone knew what that
was during this particular reading in
1938 Casey was interested in the ocean
specifically the lost city of
Atlantis Atlantis was made famous by
Plato who described the island nation in
his Works to and crius Plato described
Atlantis as a powerful island nation
with advanced technology then there was
a cataclysm volcanoes tsunamis and a
global flood destroyed Atlantis it's
been lying at the bottom of the ocean
somewhere ever since officially the
story of Atlantis is considered an
allegory Plato's warning about the
hubris of powerful Nations however many
people believe that Atlantis was a real
place Plato said he heard the story from
his Grand father who had heard it from
the Athenian Statesman Solon Solon
learned of Atlantis from an Egyptian
priest who said Atlantis was destroyed
9,000 years before that timeline lines
up nicely with the global flood at the
end of the younger dasas about 13,000
years ago during Edgar Casey's psychic
reading he confirmed that Atlantis was a
real place he said it was a large island
nation in the Bahamas he predicted that
evidence of Atlantis would be found
there specifically Al he said evidence
of Atlantis would be found in the area
of bimy in the Bahamas in 1968 30 years
later in 1968 divers were exploring the
area of bimin when they saw something on
the ocean floor that stood out from the
surrounding landscape it was a series of
monoliths giant stone blocks arranged in
a line each block was a rectangular
piece of limestone about 13 ft long 3 ft
high and 9 ft across and each weighing
several t GS the line of stones looked
like a wall or more like a road bimin
road extends for half a mile during the
last ice age the Earth's sea level was
300 ft lower the islands of the Bahamas
were one very large island and bimin
Road would have run right through the
middle of it if you look at ancient maps
like the P Reese map you can see the
Bahamas not depicted as a bunch of small
Islands it's shown as a single large
island and running right through the
middle something that looks just like
bimin Road bimin Road has spawned all
kinds of theories especially since it's
connected to an Edgar Casey prediction
that came true some say this was
Atlantis and bimy road is a remnant of
the city's ancient Harbor this also
shows that atlanteans had Advanced
Construction technology just like Plato
said other psychics say bimy Road emits
an unusual energy that produces visions
and healing powers I can't confirm that
but Edgar Casey did ufologists think
bimin Road might have been a landing
zone for spacecraft or possibly a portal
to a different dimension this portal
they say still opens and closes on a
regular basis in 1997 deep sea engineer
Joseph Mason was diving bimy when he saw
a large Square door open on the side of
a stone block the door led to an
underground passage but his Compass
started failing and the corridor
disappeared there have been strange
electromagnetic readings above themin
sometimes causing instruments to go
crazy is this evidence of portals or
maybe something else remember bimy road
is in the Bermuda Triangle in the 1970s
divers claim to have seen more Stones
aligned into more roads but those
structures have since vanished there's
still no consensus about what bimy road
is if it's a natural formation it's
unlike anything ever discovered but
while Skeptics and Believers debated
bimy Road the ocean X team was out
raising money trying to find another
trip to the UFO the Baltic Sea anomaly
it took a year but they raised the money
so now it's time we go back to the
Baltic it took a year of pitching
investors in sponsors but the oceanex
team finally had enough money for
another Expedition deep sea diving is
expensive at that time it cost about
€20,000 a day they had 120,000 in total
that means they'd have less than a week
to to find the vessel and they're
already off to a rough start a storm
forced the ship to find shelter in the
surrounding Islands waiting on a storm
is throwing money away money they can't
afford to lose the following morning
their luck turns and they've got clear
skies and gentle Seas they begin
scanning the area looking for the craft
but they have to be careful they're
running radio silent cell phones off no
connection to the outside world the
media frenzy created a lot of interest
in the Baltic Sea anomaly
but it was in international waters which
means anybody can take a shot at it they
had to be careful and avoid being
tracked snitches I got it
stitches after ducking a Navy ship they
dro the fish in the
water this is Sid scanning sonar it
paints a two-dimensional image of the
ocean floor they also use a multi-beam
echo Sounder this admits sound waves
that create a three-dimensional image of
the seabed but then they hit another
snag they lost their sonar something was
interfering with the equipment yeah UFO
jaming their stuff that's a theory they
dropped an ROV in the water to try and
track their gear an ROV is a remotely
operated underwater vehicle basically
it's a small submarine with a camera and
a grabbing arm somehow they find the
sonar cable and they repair it but this
costs them a lot of time and morale is
low 48 hours later they find the
object
it's 300 ft
down that's deep and dangerous so the
ROV goes first and they get the first
close-up images of the
anomaly they see straight edges and what
looks like concrete sonar shows a
perfectly round hole about 10 ft wide
and it's surrounded by a square frame
nature doesn't produce perfect geometry
like this they're excited to get down
there and see the object with their own
eyes but they're getting strange
temperature readings the water is about
40° F but the water right above the
vessel is below freezing well how is
that possible well they don't know then
a fog rolls in this makes deep diving
very dangerous they get the feeling that
something wants to keep them
away still they decide to
dive after descending through 300 ft
down they arrive at the object it feels
like concrete they touch it and the
material turns black they want to get in
a few more Dives but are out of time and
money diving 300 ft means you need to
take about 90 minutes to return to the
surface you have to ascend slowly to
give your body time to readjust to the
pressure return to the surface too fast
and you can rupture a lung or
worse they have to turn back and they
have another problem their 3D scan is
incomplete and there's nothing they can
do about it oh no but they brought
Hammers and chisels on their dive they
managed to chip off pieces of the object
so they return to port and send the
samples to a lab hoping someone can tell
them what the hell is this
thing when Christopher Columbus sailed
across the Atlantic in search of a new
route to India he found something else
and it wasn't the new world well he did
find that but he found something else
first like every good Captain Columbus
kept a journal of the entire Voyage his
full Journal is available and it's worth
reading but there's one specific entry
that stands
out 1492 October 11th 10 p.m. I and
Pedro Gutierrez while on the deck of the
Santa Maria observed a light glimmering
at a great distance it vanished and
reappeared several times during the
night moving up and down in sudden and
passing gleams it was cited for 4 hours
you a Columbus saw a UFO he did well
technically he saw a Uso unidentified
submerged object Columbus made his first
landfall the next day which means he had
his UFO sighting while he was in the
Bermuda Triangle there have been
sightings of underwater lights ever
since in 1644 the mayor of Boston saw
two Bright Lights rise out of the water
in 1873 the adhy sailed over something
in the South China Sea that lit up the
ocean for over an hour they said it
looked like a ferris wheel in 1879 the
HMS vulture saw a large ferris wheel
spinning in the ocean in 1880 commander
of the SS shajahan described a massive
Ferris wheel under a cal sea near
India's Coast later that year another
ship with the British India Company saw
the same object they said it was 300 yd
long those those are just a few of the
many reports of this object there are
reports of the same Ferris wheel type
craft that span 200 years whatever
objects are in our oceans they've been
here for a very very long time since the
early 1900s professional Sailors yeah
you mean steon yes say it
no since the early 1900s professional
salers and navy men have seen lights in
the water and in some cases craft emerge
from the ocean
[Music]
ACH is the Atlantic undersea test and
evaluation center this is a highly
secret Navy facility located within the
Bermuda Triangle it opened in 1967 and
it's in a remote location in the Bahamas
near very deep water at autch the Navy
tests all kinds of equipment including
Advanced weapons it's been called the
Navy's Area
former employees of ACH base have
reported mile wide craft silently
emerging from the sea they create no
sound they make no waves or Splash when
going in or out of the water 31 m
sustain
winds Splash Mark VAR range the Usos are
strange enough but the fact that they
don't disturb the water is mindboggling
no scientist has come up with an
explanation for this one researcher said
that there's a force field around the
craft that's a vacuum which is why
there's no wind or water resistance in
front of the machine they open vacuum
vacuum space this why they need this
tunnel this why they are never wet now I
don't think that works a vacuum flying
through the clouds or into water would
still disrupt it the only thing that
makes sense to me which makes no sense
at all is that us APS are somehow
interdimensional I don't know what that
is that is some
we so they exist in our universe but
they can pass through solid objects as
if their physical matter is out of phase
with
ours but we do allegedly have recovered
craft these are objects we can touch so
maybe this phase shift only happens when
the engines are running or maybe
anti-gravity technology makes a craft
impervious to air and water water
friction I really don't know but there
are more and more videos out there of
UFOs shooting into and out of the water
without disturbing a drop this is
clearly an important piece of their
technology if what we are witnessing is
a true trans medium vehicle a vehicle
that can penetrate that barrier between
air and sea or or air and space without
destruction then we're looking at a
propulsion system that is so far
Advanced it's beyond Next Generation
technology so we're probably looking at
and what it is theorized as we're
looking at is a gravitational propulsion
system a non- reactionary propulsion
system in the late 1980s Gul Breeze
Florida not far from the secret Navy
facility made Global headlines local
resident Ed Walters photographed a
glowing acorn-shaped craft hovering
above his neighborhood his images
triggered a wave of UFO sightings in the
area with hundreds of witnesses
reporting similar encounters Skeptics
accused Walters of hoaxing the photos
via Double Exposure but analysis showed
no sign of manipulation only an ominous
unidentified object Walter's photos are
still some of the most compelling I've
ever seen thing is real it can't be no
balloon no balloon man no balloon that
was real that's a real thing dude is the
real
pen where the hell did it go
gone man
gone the Earth is covered by so much
water and so much of it is unexplored
that it seems obvious that aliens or
whoever is controlling these craft would
use the ocean as a way to stay hidden in
fact there's a researcher who says
there's a whole network of tunnels
running under the ocean floor these
tunnels connect to large alien bases and
the locations of those bases are not
going to surprise
you
Cuban ufologist maximilan de lafette is
a leading proponent of the undersea
alien tunnels theory he gets his
information from sources in the military
and NASA he claims there's a vast
network of tunnels beneath the seabed
uaps use these to move quickly from one
part of the earth to the other within
this tunnel Network are hubs which
contain large bases 12 bases to be exact
and they're all over the world South
America Russia Japan and there are bases
in places you'd
[Music]
expect like several in the Bermuda
Triangle there's a base in the Baltic
Sea near the aluminum Falcon yes there
and there's a major base in Alaska Mount
Haze yes under mount
Hayes remember we covered Joseph
mcmonagle in the episode about project
8200 that was the secret CIA program
that use psychic spies to remote view
location Nations around the
world Joe and other psychics saw alien
bases in Mount Hayes and other mountains
they also saw a lot of alien activity
underwater Joe specifically said that
Usos were very busy around the US Navy's
base in the Bahamas I remot viewed for
every major intelligence agency in
America I did see some Usos that were
operating within the vicinity of
ACH now after researching this topic
it's obvious we need a full episode on
alien underwater bases so if you want to
see that that let me know there's so
much more to cover all right last thing
on this a few months ago on the after
files I covered a fascinating forchan
post foran I know I know forchan is
forchan but this person who claimed to
be a former contractor for the
Department of Defense was very
believable he says there's a large alien
base underwater in the Bermuda Triangle
the reason planes and boats disappear is
because they get too close to the base
in fact he says the Navy knows where
this base is and they specifically avoid
it the alien base can move the Navy sees
them move and they set up a new nogo
Zone he said that one plane strayed too
close and disintegrated into dust but
here are the bullet points the US
military believes the base has been
there for a long time at first they
thought a few hundred years but now they
believe the base goes back to at least
4,000 BC it might even be older though
he says there's an internal debate on
this so what the hell is it well the
base is a huge construction facility
used to develop and deploy UFOs they're
here for research and
resources the military believes the base
is operated by some kind of AI not
necessarily A sension being or group of
beings the aliens or whoever's in charge
of the base they don't really care about
humans the only time they'll get
involved is if we start messing around
with nuclear
weapons and we've seen UFOs appear on
film of nuclear tests in the past
there's even that story of something
shutting down a US nuclear missile
facility here's how the base works it
decides it wants to survey some area of
the Earth then using raw materials
within the base a craft is constructed
specifically for that purpose the craft
is built around whatever equipment is
needed if the base is going on a survey
Mission it creates the necessary
scanning gear that package is then
wrapped in a vehicle the vehicle is
deployed from the ocean it goes on its
Mission it gathers data then the craft
returns to the base and the whole thing
is broken back down again into raw
materials it's nice they recycle well
it's their Planet so no aliens just uh
spaceships that don't go to space NOP
there are aliens yes fin bump no thank
you come on fin bump for
aliens there you
go and the ships do go to space but
rarely they're here for Earth and a
little bit of the Moon again different
episode anyway this whistleblower claims
that the aliens are the Grays and
they're not fully sension the government
believes their drones are possibly even
clones they're grown as needed for
Mission support just like the UFOs are
built to be Mission specific now that I
think of it we could do a whole episode
just on this post YouTube won't let me
link to for chance SM but let me know if
you want to see a full episode on all
the details he has a lot more to say he
talks about the the materials they use
to build the power sources different
technologies that we've reverse
engineered lots of stuff a lot of what
he says is corroborated by other
whistleblowers like Bob Lazar and even
David grush now it could all be a hoax
but hoax or not it's a really fun read
and speaking of hoaxes we have to finish
our story about the Baltic Sea anomaly
oh
no Peter and Dennis from Ocean X brought
up samples of of the Baltic Sea anomaly
and sent them to a lab it was just rock
no Metals detected at all so that rules
out an alien ship The Rock was found to
be volcanic which is strange there isn't
volcanic activity in the area the theory
then changed from UFO to underground
structure maybe a temple or a building
there are features on the anomaly that
do look man-made or unnatural but the
closer you look the more it looks like
nothing more than a weird rock now on
the internet there are lots of fun
photos and images and even video of the
Baltic Sea anomaly but none of them are
real the only actual image is that first
sonar image taken in 2011 sonar expert
hanumat Singh weighed in and said that
the image isn't great if you look
carefully you can see a reflection of
the circular formation on the right side
of the image since sidescan sonar is
taken with two instruments that bounce
acoustic waves in opposite directions
from the boat a feature on one side
shouldn't affect the image on the other
side he says the reflections are caused
by electrical cross talk this means the
sonar wasn't wired properly sing calls
this strike one and he has more to say
the black horizontal lines going through
the image show that sonar signals are
dropping out that is the instruments
aren't detecting them further calling
the measurements into question a clean
properly wired sonar wouldn't have those
lines we'd have a clean image that's not
the case with the Baltic Sea anomaly
sing calls this strike two finally the
edge of of the image just beyond the
circular formation are gray meaning the
sonar couldn't tell what was there that
shows the sonar isn't calibrated well
enough to trust that's strike
three the oceanex team has been attacked
and accused of hoaxing the whole thing
it was suspicious that when they went
back the following year they had
equipment failure remember they lost
their sonar and their 3D imaging was
incomplete Skeptics say this is too
convenient and people started calling it
a scam now Peter and Dennis spent a lot
of time trying to raise money to go back
but they couldn't find the support they
blame the media for this I agree blame
the media you don't even know what the
media did oh let me guess they jumped to
conclusions without checking the facts
okay so you do know what the media did
not my first rodeo
chief after it was discovered that there
was no metal the media went hard on the
oceanex team they called it a scam every
time the team pitched investors they
were turned down nobody wanted the
sponsor a potential hoax Peter has
distanced himself from the whole thing
he was tired of being called a con man
now in defense of the guys they did go
back to the site a few years ago with an
ROV and there's more footage of
it they claim they found possible
writing or hieroglyphics on the side of
one of the stones and it could be it's
too hard to tell as of 2020 experts
believe the Baltic Sea anomaly is a
piece of volcanic rock that was pushed
in place by a gler that's why there's a
channel behind it now everyone admits it
does look strange it doesn't look
natural but until a serious well-funded
dive team goes down there and spends a
lot of time studying it we'll never know
Dennis posted on his YouTube page just a
few weeks ago that he's had a rough year
with this and other projects He had a
Russian shipwreck dive scheduled but the
war derailed his plans and he still
can't find financial support to go back
to the Baltic Sea object he thinks this
is a shame and a waste and I don't
disagree unfortunately investors want to
return on their money the Baltic Sea
anomaly doesn't have a financial upside
yeah unless it's one of the greatest
discoveries in history well it may be a
great discovery but there's no profit in
it so there's no support that's why
nobody's gone back to the moon no profit
nobody ever went to the moon look I
don't want to get nobody ever went to
the moon and I'm not going to tell you
again promise don't make me fins slap
you as for bimy Road the mainstream view
is it's a natural formation it's just
beach rock that happened to arrange
itself in that way in a perfect line
half a mile long well that's the
mainstream view ah a mainstream is
fullish watch your mouth but you're
right the mainstream is often
wrong the bimy road looks man-made to me
unfortunately there's no way to date The
Rock so we don't know how long it's been
down there whether it's connected to
Atlantis or not nobody knows there are
no other objects or structures in the
area at least NC confirmed now there is
that sunken city off the coast of Cuba
that could be thousands of years old and
if the sea level was 300 ft lower that
whole area could have held a huge
civilization but again no solid evidence
only speculation I love speculation I
know you do it's a living the last thing
we covered are underwater bases and the
Usos no no no no don't debunk those I
can't oh thank goodness we lose
subscribers when you do that now we can
and should be skeptical about post
unfortun Chan and Reddit they make for
good reading but that's not evidence but
we have plenty of statements from
Witnesses who've seen objects going in
and out of the water and by now we've
all seen footage of UFOs flying over and
into the ocean now there isn't a lot of
physical evidence of actual underwater
bases but just a few months ago an
interesting image hit the
news it's an underwater scan near
Catalina Island off the coast of
California Tim gallet a former Admiral
who is one of the Navy's top
oceanography experts says this scan is
worth investigating now this is an
admiral not just a sailor see stop it
the Admiral saw the image and says
there's no natural explanation for it
and it could be an entrance to an
underwater or underground
base I think it's about time that we do
disclose that we we are in contact with
non-human intelligence that that's what
needs to be put out there in the public
Catalina has been a UFO Hotpot for years
that's where the USS nimit wasn't 2004
when a pilot chased the UFO for Miles
we've all seen this footage the Admiral
says there's a lack of scientific
curiosity from the military when it
comes to UFOs and he's right Congress
just passed a defense bill that includes
language that gives the American people
full transparency and access to the
government's information on UFOs now you
already knew this the news called it the
UAP disclosure bill but did you know
that the Pentagon stripped all the
language regarding disclosure from the
bill now as always they can remove
anything regarding UFOs if the
information is considered a matter of
national security so that could be
anything anything the Department of
Defense can hide cover up redact
classify or even destroy any evidence of
UFOs they want any time they want no yep
Tim burett a republican congressman from
Tennessee wrote the disclosure Amendment
he said and I quote we got ripped off we
got completely hosed they stripped out
every part burchett's a republican so it
was Democrats that hosed us right nope
it was Republicans oh so Republicans are
the problem right nope our Democrat
Senate and Democrat President signed it
unip party unip
party people ask me all the time about
disclosure are we close are they finally
going to tell us and they hate it when I
tell them no no they're not congressman
burett and Admiral galludet are right
the Pentagon the milit milary
intelligence complex the shadow
government whatever you want to call it
they're not curious about UFOs they're
not curious about what they are they're
not curious about why they're here
they're not curious at all I think the
reason for this lack of curiosity is
clear why be curious about something you
already
[Applause]
know thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ you know
Heckle fish yeah it's chicken sexy
chicken fck this has been the wi
files if you had fun or learned anything
do him a favor like subscribe comment
share that stuff really makes his Fin's
wiggle like most topics we cover here
today's is recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the W files.com
tips and remember the Y files is also a
podcast twice a week sometimes more I
post deep dives into the stories we
cover here on the channel I also post
episodes that wouldn't be allowed on the
channel it's called the Y files
operation podcast and it's available
everywhere you get your podcasts now if
you want more wi- files in your life
because we all need that check out our
Discord there are thousands of people on
there
24/7 sometimes longer and they're into
the same weird stuff we are it's a great
Community it's a lot of fun and it's
free to join now if you want to know
what's going on with the channel go to
the Wi files.com that's our production
calendar there you'll see our podcasts
our live streams and what episodes are
coming your way and special thanks to
our Patron who make it all possible
every episode of the wi files is
dedicated to our patreon members without
you guys there would be no Channel I
don't deserve your support but I am
grateful for it now if you'd like to
support the channel become a member on
patreon for as little as three bucks a
month you get access to perks like the
videos early with no commercials you get
access to merch only available to
Members Plus you get two private live
streams every week just for you my
camera's on your camera's on we see each
other's faces our mouth holes work
together mono Amano aici show it's
intimate another great way to support
the channel which not as intimate but
it's still a great way to support is
grab something from the W file store oh
oh now it's time for me to plug this
stuff grab a heck of a t-shirt or a
fishable coffee mug and put a drink in
there and have a delicious beverage
while you're wearing a hoodie with my
Heckle fish face on it while you're
squeezing one of these Heckle fish
squeezy animal fish toy talking fish
toys while you play the game of Go he
ofish cut
games and that's going to do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are
[Music]
appreciated
yeah I play Bia Scara 51 a secret Cod
inside the Bible said I
was I love my youf and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck in
side M's hole with MK truck I being only
true
aware did Stanley Cube brick fake the
moon landing alone on a film set with
the shadow people
there through R well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish Thursday night Wednesday J
when through the
night all I ever wanted was to just see
the
truth all through the
[Music]
night
the MTH man Sid and the solar storm
still come to a got the the secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet are both to project State and
where the dark Watchers
found in a simulation don't
you the black KN satellite to is so oh I
can't believe I'm dancing with the fish
heck fish on Thursday nights with they J
when all through the
night all I ever wanted did you hear the
truth
the all through the
night fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
and my all through the night
all I ever wanted was to just hear the
truth so the one bat all through
[Music]
the good love to dance good love to
dance good love to dance good love to
dance yeah good loves to dance on the
dance ball because she is a camel and
camels love to dance when the feeling is
right on W in time good love dance good
[Music]
lovece